normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government all
three of them have been licking Donald
Trump's boots for years for money and
endorsements Ronda Sanz you've been a
great Governor but you would have never
been I think point you
attack same with Chris Christie as a
lobbyist begging them for covid money
for his special interests in New Jersey
prepping him for the debates last time
around these people are now Monday
morning quarterbacking some decision he
made I think the real enemy is not
Donald Trump it's not even Joe Biden it
is the Deep state that at least Donald
Trump attempted to take on and if you
want somebody who's going to speak truth
to power then vote for somebody who's
going to speak the truth to you why am I
the only person on the stage at least
who can say that January 6 now does look
like it was an inside job subject here
we 20 years about Saudi Arabia's
involvement in 911 that the great
replacement theory is not Grand
rightwing conspiracy theory but a basic
statement of the democratic party's
platform the2 election was indeed stolen
by big Tech that the 2016 election the
one that Trump won for sure was also one
that was stolen from him by the National
Security establishment that actually put
up the Trump Russia
collusion there's a reason why I'm the
only person on the stage who can say
these things that's what it's going to
take not people who were licking his
boots one time and now
also that's not his point though he
pointing out they were
sucking they're kissing his boots but
now turning on him trying to steal and
standing out of it going to turn against
them to surgeries done on miners involve
cutting off body parts at a time when
these kids cannot even legally smoke a
cigarette kids who go from puberty
blockers to cross sex hormones are at a
much greater likelihood of winding up
sterile how is it that you think a
parent should be able to okay these
surgeries never mind the sterilization
of a child and aren't you way too out of
step on this issue to be the Republican
nominate no what no I'm not because I
because Republicans believe in less
government not more in less involvement
with government not more in government
involvement in people's lives and you
know what
Megan I trust parents oh dude we should
Empower parents in education we should
Empower parents to make more decisions
about where their kids go to school I
agree we should Empower parents to be
teaching the values that they believe in
in their homes without the government
telling them what those values should be
and yet we want to take other parental
rights away I'm sorry as a father of
four I believe there is no one who loves
my children more than me and if they
want who loves my children more than my
wife there's no one who cares more about
their success and health in life than we
do not some government bureaucrat not
some you look at these Jokers down in
Congress it takes them 3 weeks to pick a
speaker and up until two days ago they
couldn't promote somebody in the
military in the United States Senate who
earns their new Rank and we're going to
put my children's health and my
decisions in their hands for them to
make those decisions for Joe Biden to
make those decisions BR they're just
saying don't give kids sex not saying
anything else say this this is not
something I fa it's AUST
Dent Megan and I get to make the
decisions about my children not anybody
else and every parent out there who's
watching tonight you start to turn over
just a little bit of this Authority The
Authority they're going to take from you
next you're not going to like parents
and I want the government stepping in
when I got my belt
out no he's got a sa of sweet Valencia
you guys are going get
to
when you were governor in 2017 you
signed a law that required new
guidelines for schools dealing with
transgender students those guidelines
required schools to accept a child's
preferred gender identity even if the
Minor's parents objected and it's said
that there is no Duty for schools to
notify par if their son or daughter
changes their gender identity allowing
this serious issue to remain a secret
between the school and a child how is
any of that Pro by way simp me
absolutely that's simply not true that's
simply not true that law was put into
effect in 2018 and regulated in 2018
before I after I was out of office no it
no we did not Megan we did not issue
those guidelines and you're wrong about
that simply wrong I have stood up each
and every time so I think if this is one
issue disqualifying it's this one I I
stood up every single time for parents
to be able to make the decisions for
their minor children but parents every
single time parents should make those
decisions and by the way you know what
every once in a while parents are going
to make DEC Politico 2017 Chris Christie
signs Bill to extend protection for away
from he is lying you don't know that
slippery slope what rights are going to
be taken away next and what's as a
parent you do not have the right to
abuse your kids this is cutting off
their genitals this is mutilating these
miners these are irreversible procedures
uh and this is something that other
countries in Europe like
Sweden they saw did incalculable they've
shut it down sign legislation in Florida
Banning the mutilation of minors because
it is wrong we cannot allow this to
happen in this country and and I know
Chris disagrees with me and I think he
has an honest position uh Nikki
disagrees with me she opposes the bill
that we did to ban that she said the law
shouldn't get involved with it you said
the law shouldn't get involved with it
also I think and this from what she did
as governor of South Carolina you they
had a bill try to say that men should go
into girls bathrooms and she killed that
bill and she bragged that she killed
that bill even to this day she bragged
that I don't think men should be going
into little girls bathrooms I think it's
wrong and I think we have every right to
protect them from
that I I I am going to come to you I I
promise him a seconds Co quickly I think
the North Star here is transgenderism is
a mental health disorder we don't let
you smoke a cig
by the age of 18 we don't let you have
an addictive drink of alcohol by the age
of 21 and I just challenge Rona s to go
one step further in support what I think
is clearly within the authority to do
using federal funds just like Reagan did
in ' 84 for the highway act that said
the minimum drinking age needs to be 21
we can do the same thing when it comes
to Banning genital mutilation or
chemical castration I know Ron's been
clear that on the federal level I'm
Crystal Clear that's where I stand
that's a mental health disorder that's
where we need to be at go
ahead it is literally a disorder Ron has
continued to lie because he's losing Li
you are lying on tape so first of all I
will say that when I was govern 10 years
ago when the bathroom situation came up
I we had maybe a handful of kids that
were dealing with an issue and I said we
don't need to bring government into this
but boys go into boys bathrooms girls go
into girls bath BS and if anyone else
has an issue they use a private bathroom
now 10 years later we see that this
issue has exploded and this shows how
hypocritical Ron continues to be when he
was running for governor and they asked
him about that he said he didn't think
bathroom bills were a good use of his
time you can go look that up I signed a
bathroom bill in Florida
believe Ron's a culture
Warrior it's the only thing he's got
these are his issues that you would say
that I was you didn't you killed it I
signed it I st for little girls you
didn't do it and there was this going on
I was actually just in South Carolina
some of the legislators told me at the
time there were boys going into the
girls that's the whole reason why they
did it and so they say when she does
that explanation that that doesn't hold
water and this is the upstate of South
Carolina I signed the bill I protected
the girl did not do South car
car no no no you are not going to talk
about my state like that because I will
tell you for fact South Carolinians
never allowed that to happen and we
hadn't we did not have that issue at the
time what I have always said is boys
going to a boys bathroom girls going to
a girl bathroom but hold on one second I
also say that biological boys shouldn't
be playing in girls Sports and I will do
everything I can to stop that because
it's the women's issue of our
time Govern of Carolina way more Trump
and way more Bas than she
ever
mram when discussing your Hindu faith in
September you seem to take a shot at
Ambassador Haley who is also
indian-american and who converted to
Christianity as an adult you said an
easy thing for me to do being a
politician is to shorten my name profess
to be a Christian and then run make vake
Vicki or whatever end quote are you
questioning Nikki Haley's Christian
convictions and why is your campaign
made a point of referring to Ambassador
Haley by her given first name nimara
even though she's gone by Nikki for her
whole life well my whole deal is if
Nikki Haley of all people should know
how to pronounce my name correctly the
rest of the news media can learn it IDE
deal is I'll call her Nikki when she
could say my own name right that's our
little fun side bet there here's what I
will say is deeper I don't question her
faith but I question her authenticity
and I think that's deeper here we were
just talking about the trans issue this
is a symptom of a deeper cancer in
American Life identity politics this new
religion that says your race your gender
and your sexuality are your identity it
is anti-American it is meritocratic it's
anti- meritocratic and it is dividing
this country to a Breaking Point and
I've spoken about this to the left my
books are all about this I've preached
this to the left but it's even worse
when Republicans try to play the same
game we're talking about that trans
issue Nikki Haley's campaign launch
video sounded like a woke Dylan mulany
Bud Light ad talking about how she would
kick in heels at the first debate she
said that only a woman can get this job
done that's what she said after the
third debate when I criticized Ron
McDaniel after five failed years of
leadership of this party and criticized
Nikki for her corrupt foreign dealings
as a military contractor she said that I
have a woman problem Nikki I don't have
a woman problem you have a corruption
problem Nikki is
corrupt kids to die who oh my God that
was actually it that was a real thing is
the problem I tweeted that thing that
somebody sent out and I thought that was
joke
photosh he did it on
purpose holy this is how this game
Puppet Masters put up their puppet and I
re he's doing that right now because he
wants it to be a mem been can everyone
know his name and I'm sick and tired of
the double standards of people that was
amazing my buddy sent me a picture of
the tweet I thought was
photosh photos this like 10 minutes AG
like resp I thought it was photoshopped
and it's real that's not him holding up
that's
it's like holy cow it was oh my God was
to you okay we got to move on to this I
love this re with the I'm going photosh
something right now actually about the
justice department and our election
system here's Tom fitt with Judicial
Watch no let's just talk about vet
crushing Nikki can we please talk about
that please the crushing Nikki no that's
uh president Trump and many of his
supporters claim AG have abused his
civil rights for the years by among
other things spying on him and now
Prosecuting him while having treated
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden with kid
gloves a recent Gallop poll shows that
Americans think more highly of the US
Postal Service than they do the FBI or
justice department what would you do as
president to restore the faith of the
American people in these
agencies well first off I'm the the only
person on this stage who's actually done
a job in the Department of Justice I was
the US attorney in New Jersey in the
fifth largest office in this country
appointed by President Bush on September
10th 2001 okay and it was an
extraordinary time in this country to be
on the front lines of fighting the
greatest attack against our country
since Pearl Harbor and I'm proud of the
seven years I spent in the justice
department and one of the reasons I am
is because I had an attorney general
when I came in named John John Ashcraft
and John Ashcraft stood up and told each
and every one of us our job was to do
one thing to make sure Justice was done
every day regardless of partisanship
regardless of gender or race or any
other consideration and that's what we
did for seven years and at a time when
our country was at its greatest moment
of danger in the last 40 years we did
exactly that and there was not another
domestic terrorist attack on this soil
so what I would do is president having
had that experience and the only one
who's had that experience is to pick an
attorney general who will absolutely do
the same thing that John ascra did to
pick us attorneys who will only care
about making sure that Justice is done
without regard to any other
consideration but the facts that are
presented and whether someone is guilty
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and the
government can prove it we have had
Attorneys General like Eric Holder and
Moretta Lynch and Jeff sessions and now
our current attorney general who have
not met that standard and the only way
you restore people's faith in the
justice system is to put someone like
that in charge of the justice department
and then it's president to get at the
hell out of the way on anything that
involves criminal investigations if a
president's involved in trying to do
something and put their thumb on the
scales Donald Trump says he will do a
shut up that makes people
be
fair talking I didn't he made
Republicans are concerned about the
legitimacy of Elections a federal judge
justed psylvia must count on dated
mailin ballots and unlike Alabama many
states still don't require any
identification to vote what should
states do now to increase election
integrity and voter confidence for the
2024 election well Tom thanks for the
question thanks for you guys do a
Judicial Watch it's really really
important there's a lot of corruption in
this government you guys are doing a
great job you should doties do what we
did in Florida 20 years ago Florida and
elections was a joke everybody would
laugh at it uh I came in I removed a
couple supervisors from South Florida we
require voter ID Universal no Zucker
bucks no Mass mail balloting and no
ballot harvesting we even have an agency
that prosecutes people for violating
election laws the result of that in both
2020 and 2022 we counted millions and
millions of votes on Election night
produced the results it was transparent
and everybody was happen that is not
happening throughout this country let me
tell you this as the nominee I think
it's important not every states where we
need it to be there is ballot harvesting
in places like Nevada all these places I
am not going to fight with one hand tied
behind my back I'm going to have
organizations in all the swing States if
they're harvesting we're harvesting if
they're Zucker bucks we're Zucker bu we
are going to exploit whatever the rules
are I favor changing the rules to be
like Florida and some of the other
states that have done a good job but
until then we have to do that and then
just on the justice department and FBI I
mean I remember being uh you know in
Iraq working with FBI on the ground and
being uh and then I was a Special
Assistant I used to have such a high
regard for these agencies what they did
to Donald Trump with the Russia
collusion was one of the biggest abuses
of power in the history of our country
these agencies need to be cleaned out
with me you'll have a new FBI director
on day one uh we're going to clear out
the doj the IRS all these places buckle
your seat belts there's going to be a
new sheriff in town all that L back in
one minute up next just once got
got phot I'm using my phone that blew my
mind dude so like Josh my buddy
downstairs was like he sent me the
picture of the meme of that of the whole
you know Haley's corrupt I thought it
was literally photosho so you had like
an aerial shot of it overhead shot I
retweeted and I like literally thought
it was like oh it's like
somebody and then he holds up holy
a long time I know stood there and the
correct angle multiple about to become a
meme Grandpa how did dicki Haley's
political career end uh just show that
picture like crush it bro yeah I am
curious to see what the polls are like
tomorrow because Chris Chris's barely
here I mean he's not talking at all and
in fact there was a whole segment where
they never even him a question I
couldn't even hear him breathing over
the mic either so no no you couldn't and
so then you have Nikki Haley who she is
holding a pretty steady position in New
Hampshire but again will this shake it
enough to put you know I would be really
curious right now it doesn't look like
vake would win New Hampshire it looks
like Donald Trump will win Iowa and New
Hampshire but I wonder who that second
place will be will that be enough there
you go thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net